Speaker 1: First big Republican hearings since
taking control of the House about Twitter and how
they backfired spectacularly and humiliatingly. I
won't refresh that story for you, but we then saw
the next hearings, the committee looking into the
weaponization, the weaponization of government.
It's hard to say it with a straight face. This
is the Republican attempt apparently to bring up
Hillary Clinton and Hunter Biden, which seems to
be that's their hammer. So everything looks like
a nail. This hearing started yesterday with two
of the most electric speakers you can imagine.
Chuck Grassley and Ron Johnson. Maybe electric is
a bit of an exaggeration. And in this first clip,
they're talking about Hillary. I mean, it's 2023
and they're talking about Hillary. Here is Chuck
Grassley, oversight of the FBI, very important
weaponization of government, talking about how
Hillary, Hillary colluded with Russia in 2016,
apparently to defeat herself. This is so if Russia
wanted Trump to win and Hillary colluded
with them, I guess, to help defeat herself.
Speaker 2: We all know now that it was
the Democratic National Committee, along
with the Clinton campaign, who colluded with the
Russians. What they used, a former Russian spy.
Speaker 1: Richard.
Speaker 2: Fusion, GPS
and law firm to create a fake dossier.
Speaker 1: This is what happens when you're
given notes you don't understand and asked
to read them. It sounds like you don't know
what you're talking about. Chuck Grassley was
not the only Republican senator who brought up
Hillary Clinton. Here is Ron Johnson, just on
the vanguard of the political criticism space,
also bringing up Hillary Clinton.
Speaker 3: My first investigation
ultimately revealed the extensive
editing of then FBI Director James Comey
of his July 5th, 2016 statement that
exonerated Secretary Clinton regarding
her use of a private e-mail server for official.
Speaker 1: What's the deal with saying Clinton?
I really don't get that anyway. So
they Ron Johnson brings up Hillary
as well. And then it really
wouldn't be complete unless
he also mentions Hunter Biden, which he did.
Speaker 3: Prior to the impeachment proceedings,
Hunter Biden's obvious conflicts of
interest in Ukraine became public.
And Senator Grassley and I began investigating.
Speaker 1: Yeah. The idea, by the way,
it's beyond this is sort of like this is
like your dog investigating who knocked
over the bin that contains the treats and ate
the entire package of treats that your dog is
not going to be a great investigator of that.
Chuck Grassley and Ron Johnson investigating
Hunter and Hillary does not seem like is going to
get you to the bottom of anything. Now, speaking
more seriously during her opening statement,
delegate Stacey Plaskett, a Democrat who is on
the committee. Because remember, even though this
is a Republican organized committee, Republicans
want this committee. They do have Democrats on
these committees. She summed up the committee
perfectly. Listen to what she had to say.
Speaker 4: I'm deeply concerned about the use
of this select subcommittee as a place to settle
scores, showcase conspiracy theories. Correct,
and advance an extreme agenda. Yes. Risk
undermining Americans faith in our democracy.
Correct. Some of today's witnesses would have
us believe that the Department of Justice and
the Federal Bureau of Investigation are part
of a deep state cabal. Right? One even wrote
a book describing the FBI itself as a threat
to democracy. The Department of Justice and the
FBI do not always get it right. History is full
of examples of these agencies getting it very,
very wrong. We have colleagues in this Congress
who have been subject to politically motivated,
hateful, racist investigations by our government.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So she completely sums it
up perfectly, which is this is another
sham committee. It's not really meant to
investigate. It is meant to prop up a narrative
that they have already decided is the truth
and to prop it up based on the preexisting
conspiracy theories and wild claims that we've
been hearing from these very same people
for two, four or even six years. So it is
yet another joke and it doesn't seem like
it's going to get any better any time soon.